welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game playing g-star 2014 mungus
Gaza fan but maybe okay let's see let's
see what could I play maybe go for Kings
Indian the same ish
yeah the thing is the best line against
the sameish probably is with c5 but I
really don't know the modern benoni so
well yeah here's c5 sm nowadays the
Maine moose leading to very interesting
play I go I go to something I'd go for
something else the problem was C fibers
that I don't really know the lines when
y takes the pawn I mean I've played the
same mission number of times and myself
of course but I as wide but I never took
the pawn and I never liked it because
black gets the initiative but it's it's
at the same time complicated I don't
know know it well ok so it's playing for
this kind of direct attack with edge
form yeah this is sometimes really
dangerous let's see quite often the good
antidote is to to get for direct counter
play on the queenside am I think I'm
going to do that c5 is some what I
wanted to do anyway and then get a
possible be five in bang co-star the
question is
mmm mmm I'm thinking maybe you can take
and then h5 it's maybe an idea
mm yeah various various ideas i mean the
normal move was just d5 of course but
maybe he can do it can play differently
may even h5 is not completely yeah it is
a bit crazy but still okay he went for
the normal move at the end yeah let's
let's go I need to get counter play at
least after h4 it's clear that white
will not cast a short anymore this is an
important important thing here the
banker gains an enormous strength of
light cannot easily Castle kingside and
secures King and after age for this is
not possible anymore if he takes on b5
the question is should I just recapture
or play 95 quite often 95 is a bit a bit
more precise as it asked right an
important question how are you going to
develop it's not so easy to develop
really okay I is doing something else
entirely really wants to get this quick
attack in but it's not it's not yet so
dangerous let's see
yeah the question is should i take or
not i have 95 as well if it takes you
we'll play age 5 of course i'm not so
clear ok and it's also a position where
you can easily spend ages ohm I was more
expecting age 5
almost expecting age five you can he can
go h5 now of course but what is this
night h5 g4 Knight f6 back and check on
age six and the g5i okay he's got some
something's going on the edge farm it
shouldn't really am lead to a direct
mate or something but it is it is
something
yeah what she definitely I think
shouldn't do is take on b5 this just he
just allows me to much play on the
queenside he needs to be straightforward
I think age 5 is the way to go if he
doesn't do that and play a slow move I
might even play a try for myself and
just block this this wasn't a bad move
anyway even though instead of b5 yeah
maybe I should have played h5 it's not
to this looks very passer okay let's not
think about it too long it's not clear
now how is going to wear ways very
warily put his King so the capture
believed it sits on c4 this is a
weakness but first let's see should I go
age five I don't know the problem is
here h5 already isn't so dangerous
anymore with this weakening on the
queenside yeah let's do this first this
has a very simple idea Queen before or
take Queen before attacking the c-4 pond
and this can easily get lost the pieces
are simply not positioned in a way to
defend the pond
what I'm talking about is something like
92 we are night GE to imagine just takes
you four takes takes Queen b4 c4 is hard
to defend he needs to play Queen d3 and
then there's 97 intending 95 and this
already is tricky maybe f4 then it's not
it's not very comfortable let's not be 6
also look b1 Quincy form yeah this is a
very simple way to play but probably a
good one one problem with this B
three-year idea is now let's say you
would switch back to the direct King
side attack aged 59 takes d4 Knight f6
Queen h6 checking Jade after that that's
immediately this piece hanging on c3 ok
so now should I take now 10 mm yeah it
really does not have anything great to
prevent it anyway and I still wonder
about the possible gh5 maybe takes takes
Queen before and then edge five come on
let's invest this one move with h5 to
stop his play it's not clear what he's
going to do next anyway one problem of
this age for advances that it's not
really working well together with f4 and
this means a knight on d5 is a very very
strong piece it cannot easily be kicked
away with their form
interesting that's an interesting wolf
it might get the night to III where it
is really better placed covering see
form
hmm not bad i'm not a bad move
hmm what should i do I may I can take c4
here because the Queen has been
protected on a five takes beat eggs and
then a queen move like win a three but
then 93 mmm okay we've got rugby aid
quickly I'm unsure i don't really want
to exchange this night only five so
probably am The Queen move hmm but we're
to be too
ok
this some yeah he really wants to get
the Queen's off I thought I thought this
is not good really because of taking in
queen d 3 but maybe I'm I'm just getting
the Queen into a very very precarious
situation maybe
hmm not clear what about if I take it
play the end game okay come on now I
don't know it is not a bad end game but
it feels bad she doesn't feel right to
exchange Queens in this position may be
back here yeah this is problem of course
just here and if he goes Queen d2 now
which you probably must otherwise that
takes you for I have a five yeah yeah
this is better this is better if he goes
Queen D 2 nite c for Queens before takes
be take see form cow it's also not bad
at all okay my dear thought a five film
that is is good does this feels right
taking a tick with the a porn i'd have
this pressure on the f are not good so
and i can i can improve my position
further with the coming Bishop a six
would be a to this kind of this kind of
this kind of approach
ok you can we can improve in with moves
like 93 m
maybe I can maybe taking and Bishop a
six is also an option young many many
attractive attractive ways to play yeah
this I was thinking about this one I'm
not sure about it he could try ever take
yeah Knight takes 191 you could try to
play a four and then just plunk
something don't be five and trying to
locate the position completely not sure
about that like to avoid it a three on
the other hand is also weakening the b3
born so it's not necessarily all
positive so Bishop a six maybe I know
I'm exchanging a somewhat bad bishop
here but progress I need to make
progress here just for a moment Queen
takes us normal-looking move as a term
has 93 ideas and controlled see forward
still you know okay this is probably
right I was thinking about route cakes
because of the c-4 possibility for that
the Queen will be six is really nicely
placed
ya know my plan my coming ideas the
pressure on them be three pawn rook b8
look before yeah the good thing is if he
goes night see for now I can just take
it okay so see going for 93 maybe
hmm yeah interesting I probably need to
move the King a way to get both nights
mobile yeah but now I can take I can
take now the thing is after all the
trades look before I suffice it's not
it's not defender why any more
defensible it's the right word right not
defendable okay still if he takes with
the Queen Queen takes rook before mmm I
know a dozen move really and politics
work before it's also not especially
attractive yeah yeah it was it was a
very problematic position I thought
maybe night bd3 to exchange a bit more
I think you're really spent too much
time with moves on the queenside instead
of just just attacking
yeah the problem with all this is it's
not just a pawn it's also the activity
you really has no active active plan
night be 3 i'm going to play wicked ok
still rook be eight yes so that after we
won i can exchange and take a form
letting a second porn
it can be can of course no enter on the
seventh but oh I can take him I'm just
briefly hesitating because of rotate to
check but I don't need to do that no
need to do that yet can always play that
move white resigns yeah it's three pawns
I'm not not sure about some things here
sorry yeah here he has many many options
of course H for some very direct 1c5
starting here he can consider many
things the question even is if he should
play d5 and I don't think d 5 is bad but
I could try i did say long castle orgy
for all these moves are are not
completely pointless even h5 it's not a
habit to the man ok this is maybe a bit
too much if you look at this and you
need to really play something like g4 to
get something going I can go here yeah
ok this is too much yeah ok here it's
already interesting to play age 52 just
stop a system his plan but ok this is
probably not bad Bishop here 95 for this
is fairly logical and here this this is
this is I think we're white needs to to
look for for some improvements ok let's
start with let's check h5 briefly
if this is some dangerous I thought I
can just take the other option is to
play the comp line grabbing this pawn
yeah maybe it's possible that there is
no threat because I mean I have two
defensive pieces and he lacks some
firepower here I have quick counter play
maybe yeah a choice is a bit crude but
it's it's still not it's not completely
crazy but here after that after that I
think it's gets it gets tricky that gets
really tricky the funny computer
suggestions in night age 52 go on those
weekend dark squares it's not bad
probably but ok I think opening up the
queenside cannot be a mistake I have
clear counterplay now with takes and
queen before Quinn before immediately
went here and then I played h5 here
maybe I can play more forcefully but I
wanted to stop this age 5 business and I
think it's not a bad choice this Queen a
3 yeah and here you really insisted on
trading maybe just here I mean age find
and age 5 is something that benefits
black but it's not it's not the end of
the world this is a play with position
provide this this was played and here i
also had this option go into the endgame
but it felt a bit weak to me check no
that's not bad not bad at all
and this is it's gettin it's gettin
problematic the queenside is so is
getting problematic Bishop a6 is an
important move there may be players who
would shy away from this because this is
the bad Bishop technically but you need
to get get progress going how do we get
ahead here and here this is just a
concrete problem he took on a six do we
see that in the game and if he doesn't
let's say you place this I go rugby aid
and increase the pressure here let's say
just for argument's sake and now let's
say take take and here intending rook b4
and c4 and I you just get the pressure
on b3 and this is more important than
the long-term consideration like a bad
bishop yeah I think this is this is
already really problematic after that
it's losing the opponent and the game
I'm not sure maybe you really should
have played something like age five
already to justify in some way the age
forms if um if you let's just the normal
move by the way here is night age three
this is something I can I could
recommend him this is a good to reply
against 97 normally because the night
has a useful place on f2 um black is
going across c6 and b5 then this is the
setup that I was aiming for it's not a
particularly great setup but it leads to
interesting play this night h3 is almost
always a good option if black plays 97
it solves the typical problem of the
sameish variation that it wad goo felt
one of the Kings Indian legend legendary
player sir once very nicely
expressed by his phrase yeah the sameish
is a nice line but ask the mud on g1
what it sings about it yeah until the
Knights thinks it should go to h3 and f2
I have a good good spot there ok thanks
for watching